NoNos panélistes : Stéphanie
GrGrandmont, Michel David
etet Christian Dufour.
AÀ force d'en parler, on n'y
ararrive. Vendredi la date buto.
JeJe parlais au président de
l'l'ordre des infirmières qui
didisaient qu'il reste 4338...
434338 exactement, plus des
prpréposés, plus plus plus. Des
gegens qui vont quitter le réseu
momomentanément. On attend le pn
dede contingence. Comment faire
dedes miracles s'il manque du
momonde?
- - On essaie de faire des
mimiracles depuis des années das
leles hôpitaux. C'est seulement
l'l'apothéose, si je peux direÇa
nene sera pas évident. Le
gogouvernement, il y a quelques
jojours, à débloquer 1 milliarde
dodollars pour essayer de
coconvaincre environ 4000
ininfirmières de faire le saut t
dede travailler à temps plein pr
rérésorber les problèmes.
IlIl y en a peut-être 4000 qui
vovont manquer à la pelle à caue
dede la vaccination. C'est un bs
dede fer entre Québec et le
pepersonnel soignant. Et dans ce
cacas-ci, ce n'est pas Québec qi
dedevait céder, ce sont les gens
ququi refusent de se faire
vavacciner, malgré le fait que
n'n'étant pas vaccinés, Sammer a
sasanté des gens qu'il soigne à
ririsque. Et donc, c'est un pas
ququ'il doit faire. Ils ont eu e
tetemps pour se préparer. Ça
ffêtent presque un an que les
vavaccins sont disponibles.
IlIls ont eu la chance pendant s
momois d'aller avec l'alternatie
dedes tests hebdomadaires.
MaMaintenant, espérons que ça va
êêtre suffisant pour les
coconvaincre et qu'on n'aura pas
trtrop de bris de service.
- - Vous dites que le gouvernemt
avavait raison de garder la lige
dudure?
- - Je pense que oui. Dans un ju
dede poker, il ne faut pas laisr
totomber ses cartes au dernier
momoment.
- - Michel, vous êtes d'accord
auaussi sur cet aspect que le
gogouvernement n'avait pas le
chchoix.
- - Certainement pas. Ça ne veut
papas dire qu'il n'y aura pas ds
asassouplissements après le 15.
DéDépendant de la situation, ona
didire que les gens qui ont déjà
unun premier vaccin et qui
s's'engage à en avoir un autre
dadans les prochaines semaines
popourrait, s'ils acceptent de
susubir des tests quotidiens,
trtravailler quand même. On n'en
esest pas là, mais ce n'est pase
momoment pour le gouvernement de
didire ça. D'une manière ou d'ue
auautre, il va y avoir des brise
seservice. Ça ne peut qu'aggravr
lala situation. Dans cette
sisituation, on tombe dans le
féféminisme. On ne parle pas de
brbris de service, on parle de
réréorganisation. Le résultat et
ququ'il y aura moins de services
etet que des gens qui, par
exexemple, sont dans une villeùu
l'l'urgence est fermée, ils vont
dedevoir aller ailleurs.
- - À Senneterre notamment dès
lulundi prochain, ils vont
rerecommencer à fermer leur
ururgence.
- - D'ici vendredi, c'est sûr qe
lele gouvernement ne peut pas
cécéder. Je suis de plus en plus
ininquiet parce que, j'espère me
trtromper, mais je ne suis pas r
quque le gouvernement et le
miministre ont bien évalué le
ririsque important que ça
cocomporte. Je trouve que depuis
ququelques mois s'est instauré u
QuQuébec une idéologie sanitaire
ququi est devenue très hégémonie
ququi est basée sur le risque
zézéro. Le mieux peut être ennei
dudu bien dans ces domaines. Ces
trtravailleurs de la santé pour
lelesquels on n'a pas beaucoup e
sysympathie. Je le répète, je ss
vavacciné et si on avait eu la
popossibilité d'avoir cinq
vavaccins, je serais vacciné ciq
fofois. J'espère que le
gogouvernement a bien évalué le
ririsque. Ce qui m'inquiète, c't
l'l'idéologie sanitaire.
PlPlus largement, jusqu'où ça va
alaller? On dirait que ça n'a ps
dede fin.
- - Vous êtes de ceux qui penset
quque le remède peut être pire e
lele mal s'il y a trop de gens i
nene se présentent pas lundi?
- - Exactement. Je ne le souhaie
papas et j'espère avoir tort, ms
ilil reste que le mieux est
paparfois l'ennemi du bien.
JeJe trouve que les ordres
prprofessionnels qui suspendent.
ilils n'ont pas le choix, mais
c'c'est rendu loin. Comme au
féfédéral, tous les fonctionnais
ququi doivent être vaccinés,
jujusqu'où ça va aller?
- - Stéphanie et Michel, vous ês
plplutôt dans les camps de ceux
ququi disent qu'il y a des preus
ststatistiques qui montrent qu'n
dodouble vacciné a beaucoup mois
dede chances de donner la malade
àà un malade et de se retrouver
lului-même avec des conséquences
grgraves.
- - Tout à fait. Je trouve que
trtrop de précautions, il n'y ea
jajamais trop. Le débat revientà
chchaque fois qu'on introduit ue
memesure. Est-ce que cette mesu,
c'c'est bien démontré que ça
popouvait aider la situation?
OnOn constate depuis un an et di
quque partout où on a prie le ps
dede précautions, ça a été mieux
quque là où on n'en a prie le
momoins. Au Nouveau-Brunswick, l
n'n'avait pas pris suffisammente
prprécautions et alors que toute
momonde à la situation à peu prs
sosous contrôle, au Nouveau-
BrBrunswick, ça explose.
JeJe ne pense pas qu'on se trome
enen prenant le maximum de
prprécautions.
- - On reçoit des messages depus
cicinq heures gens qui disent :
onon aurait été prêt à se e faie
tetester presque tous les jours.
VoVous vous passez de moi alors
quque j'aurais été prêt à fairen
gegeste, mais je ne veux pas de
vavaccin pour X raisons.
- - C'est sûr que c'est une
alalternative qui existait déjà,
avavec les inconvénients que ça
amamenait. Évidemment, c'est une
peperte de temps que de faire cs
tetests. On est pas en train de
sosoigner les patients quand one
fafait tester. Je pense qu'il ya
unune logique à dire alors et pr
ététapes. Mais cette étape, on a
dédéjà passé par-dessus. Au
féfédéral, c'est vrai qu'Ottawal
vava drôlement vite avec sa
popolitique et il ne vise pas qe
dedes employés qui travaillent
dadans le domaine de la santé ac
dedes patients vulnérables. À
OtOttawa, on dit que tous les
fofonctionnaires fédéraux, et ds
leles sociétés fédérales de
trtransport, vont devoir être
vavacciné même s'ils ne sont pas
enen contact avec la clientèle.
AlAlors, on rentre dans un
ququestionnement différent où on
sese demande : est-ce qu'il n'y
auaurait pas d'autres solutions?
SiSi je suis à la maison et quee
pepeux travailler, est-ce que ce
n'est pas une alternative
viviable? Pour les personnels de
lala santé au Québec, on a déjà
frfranchi ces étapes.
- - C'est vrai que pour le
pepersonnel de la santé, c'est
spspécial. À Ottawa, je trouve e
çaça ressemble à une dérive.
LuLundi, lorsque la date-butoira
êêtre passée, je pense que le
gogouvernement va devoir être ds
lele principe de réalilité. Il e
fafaudrait pas qu'il tienne son
bobout juste parce qu'il a décié
dede tenir son bout. Pour
teterminer, ces personnels, mais
jeje trouve que les gens qui ne
sosont pas vaccinés, on les trae
cocomme des parias. Ça devient
exexagérée. Il y a des dérapages
dadans ce dossier.
- - Ils ont le droit de ne pas
êêtre vaccinés, vous avez raiso.
MaMais ont-ils le droit de mette
enen danger des patients qui eux
onont le droit d'être dans un
enenvironnement le plus
sésécuritaire possible?
- - Vous avez raison, mais je ne
susuis pas un expert sanitaire
popour répondre. On est dans
l'l'idéologie sanitaire. Donc
c'c'est les médecins qui répondt
totout le temps.
- - Michel, un petit mot sur
l'l'aspect... à Senneterre,
l'l'urgence va quand même ferme.
CeCe n'est pas uniquement à caue
dede sa. À un moment donné, vous
ddîtes que le gouvernement refue
lele mot bris de service, mais l
vava falloir qu'on trouve des
sosolutions pour vrai.
- - Ça va être des solutions qui
vovont avoir des effets négatif.
QuQuand c'est une urgence, le
momoule dit, s'il faut faire dex
heheures de route, ça peut mette
lala santé des gens en danger.
InIndépendamment des
ininconvénients, c'est
emembarrassant. Je ne sais pas e
quque Monsieur Dubé va nous
anannoncer, mais on a une idée
trtrès précise d'où il va manqur
dudu monde est ce qu'on va fairà
chchaque endroit. Ça va être un
cacasse-tête.
- - Bon sang! On change de sujet
cocomplètement. Statut
lilinguistique de Montréal, c'et
ququand même particulier. Dans e
mmême parti... je vais vous faie
enentendre tout de suite... un
cacandidat à la mairie de Montrl
s'esest allié à Marc-Antoine
DeDesjardins. Il voulait que
MoMontréal retrouve un statut
bibilingue, des jardins, plutôt
nanationalistes, a dit non.
IlIls sont dans le même parti et
onon propose un référendum pour
sasavoir s'il y aura un
réréférendum.
- - Dans cette consultation
pupublique, on va avoir le pouls
dede la ville pour savoir si la
viville de Montréal veut un
réréférendum sur la langue pour
dédéterminer la langue officiele
ouou les langues officielles de
MoMontréal.
NoNous ne pouvons pas avoir
l'l'Assemblée nationale détermir
lele caractère de la ville de
MoMontréal. On va avoir deux ans
unun peu. Il y a des gens qui vt
vovouloir garder Montréal
frfrançais, ils vont avoir dans
leleur camp.
- - Je répète, les deux sont das
lele même quand.
MiMichel, je commence avec vous.
D'D'abord, cette idée de mettre
MoMontréal en statut bilingue, l
y y a quelques personnes qui vot
susuivre, mais ça va faire
susursauter.
- - Dans un référendum, je ne ss
papas du tout certain que le
mamaintien du caractère uniquemt
frfrançais serait gagnant. Sur
l'l'île de Montréal, je n'en sus
papas du tout convaincu. Vous
avavais tous les anglophones, ls
alallophones et une bonne partie
dedes francophones... Depuis des
anannées, on fait des sondages à
sasavoir si tout le monde devrat
avavoir accès à l'école anglaise
etet les gens des ouïes. Au-delà
dede ça, ce n'est pas à la ville
dede Montréal a déterminé sa.
C'C'est une décision qui relèvee
l'l'Assemblée nationale parce qe
MoMontréal, c'est le navire amil
dudu Québec. Si Montréal tombe,e
ririsque va dégringoler à plus u
momoins longue échéance.
C'C'est une décision qui concere
leles gens de Montréal.
sosouvenez-vous du débat sur la
lalaïcité, on a dit que ça ne
rerelève pas de la ville. Si les
coconditions du vivre ensemble u
QuQuébec, ce n'est pas à la vile
dede Montréal de les déterminer.
- - Je suis étonné, mais j'aime
êêtre étonné.
- - C'est une première. On avait
coconnu un parti à Québec
sosolidaire qui avait de co
leleader. Michèle a raison, ce
n'n'est pas à la ville de Montrl
dede décider ça, c'est au
gogouvernement du Québec. Cela
didit, étant donné qu'il y a de
l'l'anglais à Montréal, je pense
quque la norme, la prédominanceu
frfrançais sans exclusion de
l'l'anglais, devrait être une
boboussole pour gérer l'anglais
dadans une perspective où le
frfrançais est valorisé parce
ququ'il est clairement
prprédominant. Mais Monsieur, ce
n'n'est papas vraiment sérieuse
paparti. Référendum serait très
didifficile.
- - Son vote, c'est beaucoup la
cocommunauté anglophone. Mais ce
n'n'est pas tous les anglophones
ququi souhaitent que Montréal et
unun statut bilingue. Ça
n'n'arrivera pas parce que j jee
pepense pas qu'il y aura une vre
coconsultation, je ne pense pas
ququ'il va être élu. Mais je pee
quque beaucoup de montréalais ne
veveulent pas revivre les
dédéchirements de l'époque et qe
MoMontréal ville francophone, cs
acactions. Suis-je trop optimis?
- - Je pense que si il y a un mt
ququi rebute les élèves heures,
c'c'est le mot référendum. S'est
didivisé. Personne veut
s's'embarquer dans quelque chose
cocomme ça. Ça montre que leur
prpropre parti qui est issu d'ue
fufusion de dernière minute est
lului-même divisé. Je vois mal
cocomment ils vont se rendre bin
loloin. C'est un peu illusoires.
- - Sur l'idée même de décréter
MoMontréal ville bilingue, ce
n'n'est pas quelque chose qui et
tototalement dépassé?
- - Oui, on a un projet de loi 6
ququi veut réformer la loi 101.n
didit qu'on doit aller plus loin
etet en faire plus pour la
sasauvegarde du français. On n't
papas en train de revenir en
ararrière, on est en train de
paparler d'essayer d'en faire
plplus.
- - Je serai quand même assez
d'd'accord avec Michel. Beaucoup
d'd'anglophones montréalais, sin
leleur demande leur opinion, ils
vovont vouloir le bilinguisme.Ça
nene m'étonnerait pas que la
mamajorité des anglophones
prpréférerait le bilinguisme.
- - Michel, vous pensez ça? Ilse
sosont pas non plus...
- - Les gens sont pour la bonne
enentente. Si tout le monde est
cocontent, chacun a ses services
enen anglais ou en français... s
gegens haïssent la chicane.
SiSi on faisait un référendum, a
dodonnerait un oui au bilinguis,
jeje pense.
- - Les anglophones serais poura
etet c'est normal parce que ce
sosont des anglophones.
- - J'ai grandi à Snowdon, Côte-
dedes-Neiges. Il y a beaucoup
d'd'anglophones qui ne sont pas
cocontre le caractère francophoe
dede Montréal.
- - Honnêtement, Montréal, quand
onon parle de la ville de
MoMontréal, c'est déjà dans la
réréalité bilingue. Vous pouvait
avavoir des services en anglais
n'n'importe comment. Changer le
momot, ça ne change rien à la
réréalité, mais je suis convainu
quque sur le principe, les gense
didiraient : oui, pourquoi pas,
c'c'est normal.
- - Si on te demande ton avis et
quque tutu es anglophone, je pex
trtrès bien comprendre, ce n'est
papas choquant.
- - Vous ne lâchez pas le morceu
popour le cégep. Vous avez rééct
dadans La presse. Michel, vous e
pepensez pas que le gouvernement
vava changer d'avis?
- - Je voudrais bien qu'il le
fafasse mais je pense que Monsir
LeLegault a fait son lit...
- - Ce n'est pas terminé! Dans
l'l'opinion publique, les gens
acacceptent ça même si on voit
ququ'il y a une majorité de
QuQuébécois qui seraient d'accod
popour étendre les dispositionse
lala loi 101 au cégep. Mais je
susuis convaincu d'abord que le
cacaucus caquiste ne veut rien
sasavoir de sa et que Monsieur
LeLegault considère qu'il n'y a
papas suffisamment de pression r
lului pour qui s'abattent là-
dededans.
- - Stéphanie, vous pensez qu'il
fafaut garder une porte ouverte
popour des francophones pour alr
ététudier Adamson?
- - On était contre l'idée
d'd'imposer la loi 101 au Québe.
MaMais de la façon dont on va
chchanger la loi 101, on va peu-
êêtre le faire de façon
dédétournée. On va peut-être
memettre un plafond.
- - C'est moi qui dois mettre un
plplafond. S'est terminé.